l'estimable ans à l'amour à bout portant
dans une ville rose je commençais par
votre trilogie la batterie est un
immense succès en librairie c'est
complètement déjanté ça va dans tous les
sens je vous pose la question suivante
en lisant d'où vous est venue leur flash
originel il ya beaucoup de gens qui
pensent que c'est autobiographique mais
c'est l'époque du tout en fait très peu
c'est de se dire est que c'est vraiment
ma carrière de travailleur social qui a
inspiré ce roman ce que j'ai juste un
espèce d'amalgamé d'eupen situation
c'est surtout le ton je pense que le
succès de la trilogie vient de ce ton
réaliste et trash et drôle en même temps
c'est une réalité que moi je voyais sur
le terrain que je retrouvais peu dans la
littérature je me suis dit ça existe
donc ça doit être présenté et ça donne
ça c'est bien plus que 28 mille lieues
grands ouverts ces quatorze mille record
qui adoptent division global pour y voir
plus clair
vous êtes romancier poète slameur
travailleur social ou si vous avez très
dans les écoles dans les prisons comment
tout cet univers là se nourrit par
lui-même ce qui est clair c'est que l
écrit autant poézik dans les romains mon
expérience en travail social est
primordial c'est vraiment l'eau ou h 30
ma plume c'est là où je trouve mais mes
sujets de prédilection mais en même
temps est-ce que je suis allé vers le
travail social parce que cet intérêt
l'homme habitait déjà et beaucoup de
gens croient que je suis un travailleur
social qui s est mis à la littérature
mais je l'aide à bord et écrivant un mot
maudit tu peux pas étudié la littérature
qui travaillaient guapo va te trouver
vrai jam et tout l'intention d'écrire a
toujours été là quand même
donc j'ai l'impression que les deux se
nourrissent mais je pourrais pas dire si
c'est l'écrivain le travailleur social
qui prend le pas sur l'autre
en ce moment les deux sont très présents
et le pétrole
vous n'avez jamais eu la langue dans
votre poche et en tant qu'artiste
comment vous vivez une époque absolument
extraordinaire autant de la pandémie au
temps des grands mouvements sociaux aux
états unis avec la mort de georges floyd
est ce que ça vous inspire
bustos extrêmement inspirant ce moment
la prise de parole j'ai l'impression
qu'une reprise de pouvoir ont peu chiant
mais quand les réseaux sociaux tant
qu'on veut les gens sur le téléphone est
quelque chose d'efficace là dedans pour
la solidarité
il ya des changements sociaux importants
qui se font grâce à la prise de parole
publique des minorités qu'on entend de
plus en plus et de mieux en mieux aussi
donc pour moi c'est si c'est bien c'est
bon que ces crises la advienne et du
point de vue individuel
j'ai l'impression qu'il ya des gens
comme moi qui ont re découvert qu'à voir
quelques heures de libre dans une
journée pour lire écrire élever ses
enfants
c'est plutôt agréable donc avoir à long
terme si ça tient mais j'ai l'impression
que c'est bon
[Musique]
dieu dit m
la semaine prochaine vous allez lire
avec d'autres invités le discours
patriotique lors de la grande fête
nationale qui va être télédiffusée sur
tous les réseaux de télévision
d'ailleurs vous êtes natif de
trois-rivières donc pour vous ça doit
être tout un moment quand même comment
ce possible un retour aux sources aux
fameuses amphithéâtre d'être orient
c'est clair pour moi il ya quelque chose
de significatif de retourner dans ma
ville natale pour déclamer le poème avec
des amis entre autres fred pellerin
christine beaulieu qui je suis allé à
l'école donc une espèce de comment je
dirais de résonance nationale pour ma
ville natale et je suis fier d'y
participer et de prendre la parole dans
un moment où la fête nationale est peut
être des plus importantes on peut pas se
rassembler par milliers sur les plaines
mais tous les réseaux vont diffuser la
fête nationale est ce que nous avons à
dire est important et la solidarité par
les mots par la culture par la chanson
par la poésie
pour moi cette année est très
significativement justement on parle
beaucoup de solidarité par les temps qui
courent d'un racisme systémique ou si un
québécois en 2020 pour vous ça
représente quoi pour moi québécois en
2020 c'est une belle position à voir
parce que on a une culture extrêmement
riche diversifiée et même s'il ya
effectivement du racisme systémique dans
le système de justice dans la façon
peut-être aussi qui est distribuée la
richesse les ressources
j'ai l'impression qu'on a quand même une
population non seulement métissée mais
ouverte avec une volonté de tendre vers
le mieux de tendre vers le beau et on
est dans un moment de changement au
niveau international donc le québec pour
encore une fois tiré son épingle du jeu
en peut-être apportant ces changements
plus vite mieux en acceptant de
questionner en discutant en accueillant
l'autre pour moi le québec c'est une
terre extrêmement riche et résilients
d'une capacité d'adaptation exceptionnel
et peut-être qu'on va briller encore une
fois dans un contexte qui nous offre
cette opportunité
la bête goudreau quel beau moment merci
beaucoup je les ai partagé de chez les
messieurs